can I ask all three of you it's it's
very rare that people when they're
making a classic no it's going to be a
classic and as we all know with this
movie it built at what point did all of
you know you had taken part in a movie
that was going to live forever was there
a specific moment or did it just build
just kept building and building we
didn't know him at the time and we
didn't know when we heard that the UK
had voted at one of the 10 best of all
time we began to digest perhaps that it
was more than yeah it's just sort of a
sneaking feeling that kind of creeps up
on you isn't it it's just like you start
to get and like I'm in the next year you
get a little more evidence of the fact
that we have such a letdown I love there
the opening oh god at first and I was
like well gee whiz I was all upset about
it too you know I'm very because they
want why are you calling the thing the
shawshank redemption' nobody can say
that
well people really said why'd you call
it the Shawshank Redemption you you
won't believe what we hear from people
oh that was my next question
oh yeah scrimshaw reduction one way to
stop me in the elevator and said I just
saw you in the hudsucker reduction Jim
shank jams junk sometimes they say
things they don't even get one word
right it's just like a garble of
syllables I think this is this is an
important question for for anyone in the
audience who wants to be a filmmaker is
up and coming and it is going to come to
terms with negative feedback and and
Frank and I have discussed this before
and I specifically said to Frank we'd be
willing to talk about this will you be
willing to talk about the hate mail
because to me that's the most
interesting story is those hate letters
that you got sure well the first one was
from Kenneth Turan in the LA Times that
was the no no that was in a country full
of amazing reviews to get like the worst
review that you get you know from your
hometown paper when you come out is one
of the things that kind of like you know
ruined our a good time when it came out
there has been there has been a little
bit but you know I think no matter what
you do there's going to be that that
occasional disturbed person who's gonna
reach out to you because because they
happen to watch your movie on TNT that
day instead of somebody else's you know
the thing that I the thing that I really
cling to and I've saved a lot of these
things I've saved a lot of these these
letters from people for whom the movie
really meant something it really
mattered to them and you know it stopped
somebody from committing suicide or they
or at least they credit it for having
saved their life that day
you know and or the person who says I
lost 250 pounds because I saw your movie
and whatever they needed to hear
whatever reinforcement as a human being
to another human being they needed at
that moment the movie gave it to them
you know those things when you get that
in you know and you and in in the mail
you read that letter you go holy Toledo
what you know what actually has
transpired here because it is it is it
is something more than you know your
average to our to our you know time at
the at the movies have you had similar
stories that people said this to you
yeah yeah I'm sure if we both had
statements like you know the movie
changed my life
cetera cetera now I've had that I've had
it saved my life it yeah I was in a
depression and it got me out of it a lot
of a lot of very personal stories of
kind of something about the film
transformed them in some way yeah it's
pretty cool and I remember you told me
this special story about the letter you
got from the specific person who said I
hope you commit a violent crime and get
locked in prison and never make another
movie again that's the what I want you
to tell that's a great oh all you got to
do is go online they'll you'll see all
the hate mail because they love to
publish that online it's like yes we
think Frank Darabont's for good cancer
and die so he never makes another movie
it's like because their mental because
there's because they're mentally ill and
you know I mean that's that's why you
know we hope you yeah go commit a crime
so you get locked up so you never make
another movie again you know it's that
kind of thing it's all online it's it's
which is a clearinghouse for the
mentally ill really
that's why it was invented to give them
something to do yes that'll be the big
quote of the evening yes you're right
I am an idiot and I should have kept my
mouth shut actors I know that you always
come up against the danger of
typecasting the danger that once you do
an iconic role suddenly that's what
everybody wants again and again and
again did you find that after this movie
came out that you both were getting a
certain type of offer or had to fight
upstream to prove that you weren't just
this role well no what I wouldn't say
bad but I did start getting quite a few
narrative we noticed oh yes no you and
James Earl Jones could have a voice off
I didn't get any more prisoner roles
no no but you had but afterwards you
taught theater in prison yes I still do
I did it a couple weeks ago do you get
feedback from Shawshank oh yeah they
love that movie
you know it's not so much